so you mentioned obviously that's not
the normal process right now because of
kovid
is how is it different now because of
code um well um they used to
you know how i said that they used to
like uh call in people for auditions
now it's more like um you know you have
the table auditions and you get chosen
from there or um they choose someone
they're like
they don't have auditions at all and
it's kind of like they already choose
someone to oh it's like we want you to
voice this character yeah
yeah kind of thing yeah would you have
to send another tape still
um it depends on the um oh so they're
just they're just scouting now then
yeah sometimes they just scout you
sometimes you have auditions
and um when they do have studio
auditions it's more like um you're
brought in one by one
yeah so it's like you know um so there's
no like that's there's no
yeah i feel that's better for like
mental health or voice actors
but that normally doesn't give a lot of
chance for i guess new talent to trust
yeah
yeah get seen because you i mean that's
how they get seen right yeah yeah
if you if you're if you have to be
established or scouted it's quite
difficult to get seen
yeah like how do how does that work for
like the english side of things because
like it sounds
[ __ ] impossible for like new talents
to get yeah
i mean you have normally have to be
recommended like someone be like
you know it's just who you know kind of
thing i mean it's sad but yeah
kind of i mean you know there is ways
but normally it is
through recommendations and someone will
be like hey
i need this kind of voice does anyone
know someone who can do this so like
i got recommended to stuff just because
they were like we need british
and because obviously since kovid a lot
of a lot of anime dubs now
the ones that are airing like weeks
after are done
all online oh wow really
there's quite a few actually have been
done just from home studios
so they just record at home wow wow
you have to have like a good internet
connection and you have to have a sound
treated room
right which i think when covered hit a
lot of the bigger and more established
voice actors just you can order those
like
they have them in japan as well the home
office booths oh one of those things
like the sound it's like it's like a
tiny it's horrible to because
it gets so hot and you can't have the ac
on them yeah you're in this tiny room
you're like sweating
on a call and you sometimes if you're
screaming it's like terrible
yeah yeah so yeah a lot of it now
especially now it's quite bad
for like discoverability yeah you kind
of have to
recommendations yeah uh but yeah you can
you can audition for stuff still but
again to get the auditions you have to
be recommended
yeah it's it's about who you know i
guess yeah yeah i'm tough
so in in japan to even be considered for
an audition
uh i i do you have to have formal
training or they won't allow you
um no not necessarily it's like um most
of the time you have to be in an agency
yeah so like just like to get into the
agency they like
you know obviously they look at people
who have like good acting skills right
so
um people in an agency would like have
like the
you know the basic acting skills yeah
from
yeah the agent won't sign you right
i guess we can get you work and then
so um yeah like the manager picks like
who they want to um manage yeah
like yeah because managing who they want
to put forward for the audition yeah
they'll be like hey we need these voices
okay i think these guys are good take
them
yeah yeah